un hôtel transformé en salle de classe
ici des employés de la croix rouge se
prépare à prêter main forte aux
travailleurs des ch et celle des comment
aider au niveau des robes au niveau du
ménage comme emportée comme en mai après
retirer des gants comment mettre la
visière donc on leur montre vraiment la
base pour qu'ils puissent être en appui
en soutien aux personnels qui sont dans
les 6 h et celle d une formation éclair
de quatre jours mise en place par la
croix rouge
il y a quelques semaines à peine en gros
ils apprennent à intervenez auprès des
personnes âgées intervenir ces pratiques
pratiquement le cul et de la
communication à la base c'est vraiment
ça la croix rouge canadienne a reçu 100
millions de dollars du fédéral
ce montant servira notamment à la
formation et à la rémunération des
futurs employés au salaire équivalent à
celui proposé dans le système de santé
guillaume poulin fait partie de la
première cohorte vois les gens qui
étaient dans des conditions où est un
soulagement que je vous ai donné mon
aide pour passer pallier cette spéciale
pour certaines limites et aux
personnages et dès la semaine prochaine
117 de services aideront les préposés
aux bénéficiaires principalement aussi
us du nord de l'île de montréal où 54
d'entre eux seront déployés dans ces
établissements
34 seront envoyés à ceux du sinus de
l'ouest de l'île de montréal et 22 aussi
us du centre-sud une trentaine d'autres
employés aideront à la coordination
une mission bien différente de celle
outre-mer s'émeut crise avant fait
jamais vu c'est la première fois qu'on
est à rien lors d'une crise humanitaire
ici sont un territoire la croix rouge
est toujours à la recherche de
volontaires
elle doit fournir 900 travailleurs d'ici
le 15 septembre soit jusqu'à l'arrivée
des dix mille nouveaux préposés aux
bénéficiaires et d'ailleurs marie josée
en plus de leurs cours qui aurait que
ces étudiants seront formés sur le
terrain on apprend que ce sont les
préposés déjà en place qui devront les
encadrer oui dans un arrêté ministériel
signé par le nouveau ministre de la
santé christian dubé on apprend que des
infirmières
et des préposés aux bénéficiaires seront
désignés pour encadrer les nouveaux
préposés aux bénéficiaires en formation
dans les ch et celle d où les résidences
pour aînés
je vous rappelle que le premier ministre
a promis 10 mai le nouveau préposé aux
bénéficiaires d'ici le 15 septembre et
pour 70 et bien les employés désigné
recevront 5 dollars par quart de travail
donc une prime de 5 dollars peu importe
le nombre d'étudiants qu'ils auront à
leur charge
selon la présidente de la csq cette
décision est aberrante et elle démontre
du mépris envers les employés de la
santé je vous laisse l'entendre les gens
qui sont dans ris ch et celle du travail
ou de leurs 200% présentement et là on
va leur demander de former d'assister
des gens à en formation par dessus leur
tâche c'est complètement
incompréhensible radio-canada a contacté
le ministère de la santé mais ils n'ont
pas pu répondre à nos questions pour le
moment merci beaucoup marie josée merci